justement 12 papier publié sur rt france
en une semaine dont un dans lequel on
apprend qu'une enquête de l'art comme
nouveau nom du csa a été lancée dernière
article en date celui de libération
indiquant qu arte france est dans l'oeil
du gendarme de l'audiovisuel
article dans lequel il y a d'ailleurs
beaucoup de détails dans cette crise
l'ukrainienne et le traitement par rt
france on en parle avec jérôme bonnet
rédacteur en chef du site web d'arte et
france bonsoir jérôme merci d'être avec
nous tout d'abord comment avez vous
appris la saisine de l'art comme un
nouveau nom pour le csa vient
paradoxalement c'est par la presse on a
pris puisque effectivement c'est dans le
challenge qui a annoncé cette saisine
est donc effectivement on a contacté
naturellement nos services sans contact
et l'art comme pour leur demander ce
qu'il en était il nous a été répondu de
ne pas nous inquiéter qu'effectivement
il reconnaissait bien être saisi et
disait pas par qui pourquoi il disait on
va examiner les éléments qui sont portés
à notre connaissance et s'il ya matière
à notre sens nous reviendrons vers vous
c'est à ce moment là que nous recevons
de deux journalistes de libération une
série de questions et e pour le coup
semble vraiment très très bien informés
sur la procédure en cours et surtout sur
qui a lancé cette saisine auprès de
l'arc amont c'est à dire cette fameuse
session médias démocratie liberté la
question évidente on a envie de vous
poser c'est qu'ils sont ces gens eh bien
oui et alors on sait tout de suite
effectivement poser exactement cette
question stéphanie alors on m'a regardé
et sur internet on n'a rien trouvé du
tout quelqu'un de curieux pour une
association alors on regarde le journal
officiel et on s'aperçoit que l à huit
mois d'existence a été créée en juin
dernier alors huit mois c'est à la fois
court dans la vie d'une association mais
c'est long pour n'avoir strictement rien
fait parce que si on regarde sur
internet encore une fois y'a pas un
communiqué il n'y a vraiment rien et
donc on se demande un peu ce qu'était
cette inflation cas ressemble quand même
à une coquille vide et puis on avait
trouvé la trace également de leur
adresse mail immeuble ou ici parisien où
ils sont censés se trouver il ya rien
qui alors non enfin c'était vraiment
très étrange et puis à ce moment là donc
paraît ce fameux article de libération
et là on en apprend un petit peu plus
sur eux alors alerté et bien
effectivement c'était celle étrange
parce que on
on voit que c'est une station dont le
vice-président est un lituanien qui
regroupe une dizaine de citoyens issus
d'europe de l'est et on se demande un
peu pourquoi cette soudaine passion pour
le paysage audiovisuel français
il va en fait les seuls aliments qu'on a
dans libération qui permettent de
développer une théorie c'est que ces
gens se disent ouvertement anti kremlin
donc peut-être pense-t-il au travers de
rt france atteindre la russie ce qui est
un peu ridicule mais c'est les gens de
le penser alors pourquoi commencer
justement par la france les bassins
c'est assez intéressant stéphanie parce
que ce qu'ils disent c'est qu'ils ont
trouvé il dit vouloir toucher toutes les
antennes de rtl et 10 on espère que
l'initiative fera tâche d'huile dans les
autres pays européens donc il s'agit
bien de d'attaquer toutes les antennes
de rtl
néanmoins pourquoi la france parce que
selon leurs termes il y retrouvait le
contexte alors excusez moi le terme
barbare de juridico administratif le
plus probable alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire juridico administratif
à mon avis pour ce qui est administratif
c'est peut-être que le gouvernement
français n'a jamais caché son hostilité
envers un thé france donc un contexte
favorable de ce point de vue là et pour
le côté juridique qui a évidemment la
loi anti fait qu news rappelle que cette
loi a été dénoncé à l'assemblée lors de
son adoption par certains députés
notamment jean luc mélenchon qui disait
qu'il s'agissait sous couvert de lutte
contre la désinformation d'attaquer
directement certains baignade dont rt
france et là les choses sont très
claires pas tout à fait injustement
c'est pas clair du tout merci enfin vous
votre rubrique était clair mais ce qu on
y lit effectivement n'est pas toujours
très clair merci jérôme bonnet rédacteur
en chef d'arte et français